there's always more to it than you think
there is and even and in the rare
moments where it is somewhat overnight
they're also gone overnight really
always right so in situations where
someone genuinely just blows up super
quickly out of nowhere
they never last they didn't see it in in
music and anything
do you see the demilios um do you know
who they are
demilios i don't know oh my gosh you
don't
i'm shocked um they're you're not you're
not on tick-tock are you no
unfortunately okay
you say fortunately yeah oh i love tick
tock um
no it's this girl she's like 16
and she went from zero to
120 million followers
okay which is good and yeah which is
insane so i wonder when you built a
platform that big
how does that go away overnight
um well what if tick tock dies in two
years
that's possible yeah i mean look there's
i mean if you think back to the big
youtubers back in the day yeah a lot of
them most of them are gone like you
remember who is if you remember who was
pop in like in i don't know 2010 like
early big youtubers
a lot of them went away i'm not saying
like in every single case like in her
case if she's smart and she's able to
sustain that and she's built some proper
depth with her audience then she'll
she'll be good right even if tick tock
dies she'll shift to another platform
and she'll entertain people elsewhere i
don't even know what she does um but
obviously she's got some talent to be
able to do that yeah so um
in so that that can definitely be done
but generally
with a lot of things it's it's easy come
easy go
that that's the general
that's the general thing right i mean if
you look at the world of music look at a
musician who oh their first single just
blows up
okay right versus the artist who
oh their 30th
single blows up right because then
they've already they know how to do live
shows they know how to perform they know
how to write songs like they didn't it
wasn't a fluke they've put in all that
work they've built their mindset they've
created some depth with their fan base
they've built credibility etc
so that when they get that break
cool like they're around you know ed
sheeran is going to stick around until
he's in his 70s if he wants right i mean
i knew about ed sheeran i discovered ed
sheeran in 2008 like manny i remember
when i had more twitter followers than
him
um but you know like i've you know
chatted with him online before so but he
put in you know a good decade pretty
much before he kind of blew up to the
level and it's the same whether you're
talking rappers or singers or whatever
the people who tend to really last can
have these multi-decade careers it
generally took them some real grind and
leg work to get there and then it means
that they're prepped and they're ready i
mean it's it's like me now i mean if
i don't know say in 2009
i'd had that video blow up in 2009 not
that it was possible because you know
men were still men and women were still
women in 2009 but if i'd had that
opportunity to even go on joe rogan and
go on ben shapiro and do this and do
that
i wouldn't have been i wasn't ready
right like i wasn't ready even just as a
human being
i
wouldn't have been like the way i'm
talking to you now on this podcast if
you spoke to me 10 years ago i wasn't as
articulate and able to
condense these thoughts and i didn't
have all this experience to even draw on
and talk about in in anything or when it
comes to live performances right i mean
if someone blows up off their first
single and you're like hey we're gonna
put you on a festival come perform to
twenty thousand people
they're gonna suck
right now they haven't performed yet
right like they're they're they're a
noob right it's like
okay like
first day in the gym we're just gonna
whack on you know
100 kilos on the bench press
and just you you're right you're going
to get flattened because
you can't skip experience you know you
can't skip experience right like the
only way you get experience is by doing
something
a lot of times right if you put out
a video or a podcast or something and
like your first one just gets lucky and
somehow catches the algorithm and it
blows up
you don't know how to capitalize on it
right you see this on twitter right
you'll see a tweet go viral and it gets
100 000 likes you click on the person's
following and they have like 800
followers i'm like dude if that were me
i would have turned that 800 into twenty
thousand
but they don't do it i don't know how to
do it because they just got lucky right
they're just lucky they caught the
lightning and they don't know how to
actually
use these opportunities that they get i
mean i so i when i had that flash in
2019 i mean it's funny that we're still
that we're even talking about it right
because yeah that tweet was over two
years ago
oh wow yeah it is right and people
didn't just forget about zooby after
that yeah it wasn't just like oh you
know tweets go viral every single day
yeah but everyone is not parlaying that
into hundreds of thousands of followers
and releasing books and podcasts and
doing this and doing that and getting on
rogan and getting on this and getting on
that right it's like you have to be able
to do that but for me to
for me like i i knew i was ready right
for like i'd been ready i'm like oh man
i've been ready for like
i've been ready for like uh i don't know
it's come 2009 i'm like okay i've
probably been ready for like five years
alright i need that right give me that
crack and i'm gonna kick the door down
right give me that opportunity and i
will kick the door down right give me
the opportunity to perform in this place
i will blow that crowd up give me that
opportunity i will um
but at the early stages even though
we always want you know we all want
success immediately right yeah we want
it yesterday but i mean it's no
different to any other career i mean
think about it
how in in what career do you expect to
get hired and become the ceo within two
years
none right like crazy person like no
right you're not gonna get hired by a
company and you're like okay cool so i
want to be partner like in 18 months
right but people will jump on youtube
and be like okay like i want to blow up
in a year right like
man like you know i'm not saying it's
impossible right right people have blown
up in a year yeah but it is not the norm
like talk to anyone on youtube who has
even a hundred thousand plus subscribers
let alone a million plus right and see
how long they've been going like
normally
again
normally at least five years
often closer to ten right well
the reason i ask this question is i just
see i've seen so many um just being on
tick tock i've seen so many tick tockers
blow up and get more followers than like
people have that have been working for
10 years sure have got do you know what
i'm saying so it makes sure no i don't i
don't doubt it i mean yeah like i'd say
firstly a lot of them i'm sure are not
making a lot of money some of them will
be a lot of them
right a lot of them won't be making
money um and two
you know we can come back in 2025
and see how many of these
you know do you remember vine do you
remember vine
no i never had it
okay well where are where are all the
vine stars
i don't know
nor do i okay where all the my where all
the myspace
okay my space stars right so
you know and a couple have stuck around
you know like jake paul used to use vine
and he was able to parlay that into a
gigantic youtube following and obviously
like he's again he's smart he knows how
to capitalize on that so whatever
platform you give him he's gonna know
what to do and you know whether love him
hate him whatever he and his brother
know
you know they have very smart marketing
and branding minds they know how to do
it they know how to monetize they know
how to catch attention so on and so
forth um but the truth is like you know
there have been other platforms before
you know i mean vine was kind of like
tick-tock before tick-tock really
okay
and even even snapchat like snapchat is
still around but
it's not it's already peaked okay right
yeah actually that's true yeah so like
there were big snapchat stars
right like they mastered they got on
like really quickly they kind of blew up
build a big following
but it just wasn't
sustained so much so i think
you you also have to learn those kind of
fundamentals because different platforms
work well for different people obviously
like twitter is my best platform but if
you know twitter somehow goes the way of
the dodo i have built enough you know
knowledge and xp like it would be a blow
but i've built enough knowledge and
expertise and audience etc so that
okay i know
i understand the sort of fundamentals as
to
why
i was successful there and how i built
that audience and it was it wasn't just
luck it was like okay cool there was a
strategy there so then if you can apply
that to different things then i think
you're i think you're always good um but
yeah i would say you know i mean and i'm
not saying like i hope these people like
i say i don't use ticket talk like i
hope these people who are getting these
millions and millions of followers on
tick tock i do genuinely hope that a lot
of them
are able to
capitalize on that properly and turn it
into something long and sustainable
um
but people need to
do that deliberately rather than kind of
just
stumbling into it and not really knowing
how they how they stumbled into it
yeah no the main reason i wanted to get
your opinion on that is because i
haven't followed any social media people
long enough to know who sticks around
and who doesn't okay
so i actually don't
really know
um
it's very i'll tell you it's very easy
to see on on youtube in on youtube
twitter and instagram it's very easy to
see actually
because they've been around and facebook
as well because they've been around for
long enough
that you can see i mean if you go back
if you go on a big youtuber's channel i
mean you can go back and watch their
first videos in most cases yeah so you
can see oh wow this guy's first video
was in 2005. so this guy's been going
for 16 years and
like
they've really really really built this
thing up you know
um just like with music you can go back
okay when did this guy release the first
out oh wow okay this guy's been going
for
maybe i just heard about him today but
like he's actually been going for a
really long time or same with podcasts
etc
what um so that actually leads into my
next question of your success what
percent would you um say is hard work
luck or talent if you had to give a
percentage to each
um
wow that's a good question i've never
been asked that
um
hard work luck and talent
i'm going to say it really depends on
how i
think about it
because it depends on kind of how far
back
kind of depends on how far back you go
right like does luck include the fact
that i was born
in the internet age and to a two-parent
household in the western world right no
no or are we just talking like yeah you
know what i mean i'm talking luck as in
um you were born like just against
everyone that was born in present day
gotcha okay i will say
let's say
let's say like 65 35
60 i said um hard work luck and talent
yeah 65 35 percentages okay
yeah 65 hard work five percent luck and
35 talent
oh i just can't do math
you were looking at me real mad weird i
was like did i like yeah right i just i
just can't i just can't count out never
mind okay
[Laughter]
okay um
have you ever thought about moving to
the u.s
yeah
um i've actually applied for visa most
people don't know that but um hopefully
i'll get a visa next year we'll see
what so